You have no right to wave your finger in front of a Polish face
you have no right
until you settle the corruption scandal
from the invasion of German Belgian services
Accept and do not teach us about the rule of law.
How symbolic it is
that when Poland fell into Soviet hands
After the German attack
brought peace to the Communist Party
when the Germans swam in luxury
We fought the communists.
The one who just appeared
Member of the Communist Party
Known for exercising power.
brought by the communists
now attacks the democratic government elected eight times
How symbolic it is
you have no right
Teach and teach us about the rule of law
Judges tsue
who went hunting with lobbyists
You have the right to speak about the rule of law.
if you do not account
You have no right to teach Polish